and finally new rule now that
president-elect Trump has set a record
for getting white votes in America we
all must face up to one fact the
anglo-saxons are not sending us their
best people but we can't build walls
that's not the answer like it or not
we're living with Trump now even though
that kind of sounds like one of those
prescription drug ads you hear on TV I'm
living with Trump but I'm not letting
Trump control my life
[Applause]
so one thing the pundits seem to agree
on now is that America has never been so
divided although I'm thinking it may
have been worse during the civil war but
it's definitely the most divided I've
experienced in my lifetime and I lived
through the traumatic Punk versus disco
wars of the 1970s we've always had our
disagreements here but now half the
country literally wants nothing to do
with the other half our motto is no
longer a pluribus unum it's go [ __ ]
yourself and that is not a sustainable
way to live what it reminds me of is I
think most people in their lifetimes
have had the experience at one time or
another of having to live with someone
you hated we've all been there right
some version of roommate Hell where if
they were in the living room you stayed
in the kitchen and if they were in the
kitchen you stayed in the living room
and if they were in the bathroom you
peed in a jar you don't give him his
phone messages and while you're out he
drags his balls across your pillow
you could go weeks without acknowledging
the other person it was like living with
a ghost who never washes the dishes
eventually you end up ignoring each
other's existence living in the same
place but not really seeing each other
which is sad but on the bright side it
does prepare you for marriage well
that's where we are as a nation right
now I'm looking at all these jubilant
Trump fans and thinking what happened I
don't even know who you are anymore
and they're looking at us thinking [ __ ]
but we're here we're stuck here oh sure
people talk about moving somewhere more
progressive like Canada or North Korea
but but most of us Hillary voters still
have a soft spot for this crazy mixed-up
country of ours it's where we first
learned to ride a bike and first ran
after the ice cream truck it's where we
served as an altar boy in our church and
later sued the church for what happened
when we were altar boys it's where we
developed our first peanut allergies got
our first regrettable tattoos puffed our
first glue behind our first dumpsters
it's where we played Monopoly during
summer vacations never imagining that
going bankrupt in Atlantic City was a
stepping stone to the White House
plus all our stuff is here
it's tempting to want to divide America
down the middle right now I've actually
been in the bad roommate situation where
you literally got white tape and made a
line through the middle of the apartment
it's something they've tried on many
many sitcoms over the years starting
with I Love Lucy Lucy on one side the
spanish-speaking immigrants on the other
she just wanted to make the living room
great again
maybe liberals and conservatives need
couples therapy a safe space where
liberals can say to conservatives your
obsession with guns makes me
uncomfortable and conservatives can say
to liberals we feel bullied when you
demand that we make gay wedding cakes
but that's probably not gonna happen
you can unfriend someone who's politics
you don't like but you can't unfriend
47% of America roommates can move out
Patriots can't America needs you more
than ever right here with me and the
rest of the resistance
until we can figure out how to really
make America great again and don't ever
let them forget we're still here
[Applause]